here's the 3-2 to grossman again drives
it to right field into the corner and
that ball is off the wall
solaire hustles to pick it up and robbie
grossman continues to rake against
kansas city it's a leadoff double
well he works the count right and that's
what he sees ball that was the ball that
he took
for uh
strike two
and he gets another fastball up and away
and this time he's able to
put a nice swing on it drives it right
down the right field corner
which takes plenty of time now he's got
some activity on the bases so came to
larry the other way and under the glove
of the first baseman o'harn grossman's
gonna score and the tigers in the first
score first thanks to jamer candelario's
rbi single one-nothing detroit
a lot of his hits this year have not
been absolutely crushed but i think he
has a pretty good idea of what he's
trying to do this ball gets by o'hern at
first base driving to his right of
course robbie off and running so he's
going to score easily two on one out
eric haas off to a 9-27 start
putting pressure on aj hinch to keep him
in the lineup against lefties for sure
and he bloops one into center that will
drop in front of taylor candelario's
gonna try and score the throw to the
plate's not in time it's two-nothing
tigers on the rbi single from eric haas
eric kind of follows mickey there he
gets jammed a little bit this is a
four-seam fastball you can see it
doesn't hit
pretty much right on the label
but he finds a hole out in front of
michael a taylor
and uh numbers not all that great
against kansas city he's one and one
with an over six era so he wants a
little redemption here
waving a miss by merrifield quick work
against kansas city's lead off hitter
one away
and the preparation that he brings to
the table is
beyond reproach he and eric hoss grayson
grinder as well
this one rolled over to cabrera
it's a nice inning for casey mize to
start here in kansas city
sometimes you have to almost have a
sixth sense but more than anything else
you have to execute
like that that's good execution second
strikeout of the afternoon for casey
mize he gets gutierrez swinging
i'm not saying at your house when you're
having the debate with your wife i'm
saying watching baseball games good
strikes out o'hern
back-to-back punch-outs to end the
second for casey mize
so
that's a good sign
he strikes out solaire to start the
third and now a fastball
but casey's almost
has an advantage already it's amazing to
me
trust the outcome and the outcome is
another one two three inning for casey
mize he's faced nine he struck out four
and he's picking them up and mowing them
down in kansas city early
the whitmerfield remains the toughest
out in this kansas city lineup he and
carlos santana and they will bat against
casey mize here in the fourth
mirrorfield sends one to right
and robbie grossman with a diving grab
to make the out on whit merrifield to
lead off the fourth
it's it's amazing to me because whit
merefield
on a non-magical day
is going to have that one drop because
that's what he does he's the best there
is at flaring them to right he's learned
and he's settling in
and in tendy is the
first royal to reach base
and up comes perez
okay the perfect game is gone you got
him talking to himself and he hasn't
given up a hit yet time for salvi to put
one in the drink and he wants him to
think that he's gonna throw up a
splitter
salvi then muscles and it goes off the
glove of the shortstop goodrum into left
field nico left the ball play him that
well that's going to be rule to hit
and like you said he let it play him and
the official scorer gave him a hit on it
now
typically instead of waiting back on
that you'll go get that short hop that's
it that's an easy short hot pick
and you know good drum is just not a too
short stop
ooh
and now he comes inside and hits
merrifield in the rib cage
[Applause]
they called a swing on it though oh
matheny's going to have something to say
about that
let's see where it got him
oh whit is
with saying i was just trying to get out
of the way
man that's a two seamer that two sema
run oh no fingers
right on the left fingers oh man well
you hope he's all right he's walking
that one off that's two in a row
and he's got to stay in there and hit
again
did they just throw out mike mclean no
but watch out here comes the skipper
adrian johnson just threw out mike
matheny and mike was walking back to the
dugout
yeah you know what matheny it can be
intimidating too
this guy he's a big man and and his wife
never loses it like this but i don't
blame him let him have it it's his best
player whitmer field
mike was walking back to the dugout and
it was like johnson was staring him down
oh well you know what that's their job
they've been doing it a long time and
[Applause]
he made a call based on his
education in the game
he pulls it to lopez coming home and
they have
got him at the plate
scott barlow
nice job nikki lopez got the ball
initially he couldn't find the handle
and then quickly
found it salvi quick with a tag got it
get that tag down on him before he gets
in there that's nicely done
he's up there to hit hack
you know
soto he wants
the strikeout
put it in play you get a run
tries to dump it to right but he'll be
caught by grossman tagging at third
racing home has been intended he will
score throw to third is
he came off the bag gutierrez going from
second to third
the royals do get a run because
penintendi had crossed home plate
gutierrez came off the bag with that
left hand
can't tell this angle here he said look
at that on par i mean he's right there
on top of it yeah he's saying he's off
now i don't it didn't look like it
candelario pushed his arm off at all
[Applause]
he is out the inning is over the royals
do score a run because ben and tindy had
touched home plate before
the out recorded at third
big guys coming up in santana benintendi
and perez
and well
center field jones back
it's a goner and the royals win it
walked off santana
what a huge lift for his ball club
carlos santana
showing some evil ways against the
tigers to finish it
and the monarchs come through first
pitch that ball was down and away at 97.
he supplied the power
no question did folmer easy swing
and the ball jumped and the crowd is
going home happy here
no doubter
[Applause]